This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目“2%”中，我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，展现精神坚韧、保持健康以及培养韧性的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听“2%”。也就是数字“2”加percent，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何收听播客的平台订阅《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方谈论其实并不安全，但你是在跟一位经验丰富的执业专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须去这么做。欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听并学习《艰难成长的教训》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试作假了两次，对吗？我作假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于承担了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨一些二十岁时面临的重大生活转变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today we're talking about a topic we haven't spoken much about in the past. I actually don't think we've ever spoken about it at all, but when a listener suggested it,
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目。今天我们要讨论一个过去我们很少谈论的话题。事实上，我觉得我们以前从没谈过这个话题，但是当一位听友提出这个建议时，
it just absolutely grabbed my attention, not only as something that I have personally struggled with in the past, but also as somewhat of a quintessential 20-something experience and an experience, a phenomenon that has a lot of psychological underpinnings. And that topic is chronic oversharing. I think we've all been there. Let me tell you, we have all at some point in our lives said too much, said something we know we shouldn't have, and felt incredibly awkward in the days and the weeks that have followed. But why exactly? Do we as humans sometimes feel this intense impulse to tell people things they probably, A, don't want to hear? And B, we perhaps don't even want to tell them. So today we're going to break it all down. All of the psychology behind. this tendency. What exactly is oversharing? How is it different to authenticity? Why do we feel that embarrassment or that vulnerability hangover in the days that follow? And also just why do we do it?
它绝对吸引了我的注意力，不仅因为它是我个人过去一直在挣扎的事情，而且它某种程度上也是二十多岁年轻人的一种典型经历，这种经历和现象背后有着许多心理学基础。这个话题就是：慢性过度分享。我想我们都有过这种经历。实话告诉大家，我们都在生命中的某个时刻说得太多，说了一些我们明知不该说的话，并在随后的几天和几周里感到无比尴尬。但到底是为什么呢？作为人类，我们有时会有这种强烈的冲动，去告诉别人那些他们可能：A，根本不想听；以及B，我们其实自己也不想告诉他们的事情。所以今天我们要彻底剖析。这种倾向背后的所有心理学。到底什么是过度分享？它与真实性有何不同？为什么在接下来的几天里我们会感到那种尴尬或脆弱感宿醉？还有，我们到底为什么要这么做？
Where does this come from? I also think most important of all is how do we identify the line between vulnerability and oversharing and prevent ourselves from crossing that line and maybe disclosing more than we are comfortable with. There is so much to discuss. It is such a fascinating concept, but let's firstly start with the basics. What exactly is oversharing? I think we all have an intuitive idea of what it means to overshare, to look back at a conversation as I said and just realize that this person now probably knows a lot more about us than we are comfortable with. Essentially, to overshare is a tendency to disclose an inappropriate amount of detail about our life to the wrong person or at the wrong time. I've been there, you know, being a bit too drunk at a
这一切源于哪里？我还认为，最重要的是，我们如何识别脆弱与过度分享之间的界限，并防止自己跨越这条界限，从而可能透露出超过我们舒适度的信息。有太多内容要讨论了。这是一个非常迷人的概念，但让我们首先从基础开始。到底什么是过度分享？我想我们对过度分享的含义都有一个直观的理解，就像我说的，回想一段对话，然后意识到这个人现在可能对我们的了解远超我们所能接受的程度。从本质上讲，过度分享就是倾向于向错误的人或在错误的时间透露关于我们生活的、不恰当数量的细节。我也经历过，你知道的，在聚会或工作活动上喝得有点多，
party or a work event and suddenly revealing some deep childhood secret or something about your friend that you know you shouldn't have shared. And that tendency comes from a lot of places. Sometimes it's social anxiety, just feeling so nervous in certain situations that you just try and find anything or any way to connect with others. Or you overshare because your anxiety has lowered your filter or your impulse control. There's also explanations to do with neurodivergence that we're going to touch on a little bit later. And also it might just be because you feel inadequate or boring and you're looking to your most embarrassing story, your most vulnerable moments to kind of feel a void in a social situation and make you feel more interesting. It also is a way
然后突然吐露一些深埋的童年秘密，或者关于你朋友的某件你知道不该分享的事情。这种倾向有很多成因。有时是社交焦虑，在某些情况下感到如此紧张，以至于你试图寻找任何东西或任何方式来与他人建立联系。或者你过度分享是因为你的焦虑降低了你的防备或冲动控制能力。还有一些与神经多样性相关的解释，我们稍后会简要探讨。另外，这也可能只是因为你感到自卑或无聊，于是你翻出你最尴尬的故事、最脆弱的时刻，来填补社交场合中的某种空虚，让自己显得更有趣。这也是一种
to speed up relationships to make people feel closer to you on an advanced timeline or just because we feel lonely. When we feel like our relationships don't have much depth or we're feeling detached, we can use oversharing, often subconsciously, as a means to create new bonds by escalating that depth of emotional intimacy. I think reasons aside, because we'll talk about them more in depth in a second, chronic oversharing, the repeated habit and behavior of sharing too much detail, it can also cause us a lot of regret and embarrassment, leading us to engage in some negative self-talk, telling ourselves that, you know, we should just shut up and that we're cringe and that people think we're weird. And I don't think that you deserve to feel that way or to have that
加速人际关系、让人们在提前的时间线上对你产生亲近感的方式，或者仅仅是因为我们感到孤独。当我们觉得自己的关系缺乏深度或感到疏离时，我们常常会在潜意识里利用过度分享作为一种手段，通过提升情感亲密的深度来建立新的纽带。抛开原因不谈，因为我们稍后会更深入地探讨它们，慢性过度分享——即分享过多细节的重复习惯和行为——也会给我们带来很多后悔和尴尬，导致我们进行一些消极的自我对话，告诉自己说，你知道的，我们本该闭嘴，我们真让人脚趾抠地，别人觉得我很怪异。我不认为你理应承受这种感受或对自己进行这种
internal dialogue about yourself. I think it's less about the impression you're making on other people. I think that is a secondary consequence of oversharing and more about how it makes you feel about yourself. It's an important thing to remember that most of us have the best intentions when it comes to oversharing. As humans, we often use stories and personal disclosure as a way to build connection and to communicate our authentic selves to really show people who we are at our core. And there's often this very thin, intangible line between oversharing and being authentic. And I think the reason why that line is sometimes hard to see is because both acts, feel very similar in the moment and we can kind of struggle to identify what is meant to be kept
内心的对话。我认为这与其说是你在其他人留下的印象，不如说这其实是过度分享的次要后果，它更多关乎这种行为如何让你对自己产生感觉。有一点很重要，我们需要记住，当我们进行过度分享时，大多数人其实都怀着最好的意图。作为人类，我们经常把故事和个人披露作为建立联系的一种方式，用来传达我们真实的自我，向人们真正展示我们内心的核心是谁。在过度分享和保持真实之间，通常存在着一条非常纤细、无形的界限。我认为这条界限有时很难看清，是因为这两种行为在当下感觉非常相似，我们很难辨别哪些应该被保留为
private and what can be shared, not just with close friends and family, but with acquaintances or co-workers or even strangers. So authenticity often comes from a very core place of honesty and realness. It's about not being afraid to share who you are regardless of the pressure you're under to do otherwise, regardless of the pressure you're under to look or act or behave a certain way. And part of that authenticity is being open and honest about your feelings and your experiences. Part of that is disclosure and sometimes making public what we often imagine to be private. We see this online a lot, I would say. That's like the best example I can think of where we have creators or influences.
私密，哪些可以分享，不仅可以与密友和家人分享，还可以与熟人、同事甚至陌生人分享。因此，真实性往往源于诚实和真实的内核。它是关于无论你面临多大压力去做其他事情，无论你面临多大压力去以某种特定方式展现、行事或举止，都不要害怕分享你是谁。这种真实性的一部分就是对你的感受和经历保持开放和诚实。其中一部分是披露，有时是将我们经常想象为私密的事情公之于众。我们经常在网上看到这种情况，我想说。这就是我能想到的最好的例子，那些我们称之为最真实的创作者或网红，
the ones that we would call most authentic are normally those who are most willing to share personal details about themselves. And I think the reason why we call that authenticity is because truth and sharing and vulnerability, it builds relatability and it builds a sense of closeness. Essentially, we can look at the things they are saying, look at their stories, and we see ourselves in those moments. We see what we are personally going through reflected back at us and that causes us to feel less alone. So in that way, I think what some people may typically see as oversharing is also incredibly healing, not just for the person who is sharing this information,
通常都是那些最愿意分享关于他们自己的个人细节的人。我认为我们称之为真实性的原因在于，真相、分享和脆弱性能建立共鸣和亲近感。本质上，我们可以审视他们所说的话，审视他们的故事，并在这些时刻看到我们自己。我们看到我们个人正在经历的事情在我们身上得到反射，这让我们觉得不那么孤独。因此，从某种意义上说，我认为有些人通常认为的过度分享，同时也具有不可思议的疗愈作用，不仅对分享这些信息的人来说是如此，
but for the audience or those who are listening in. I think our acceptance of this level of candor really represents, I think, a pretty significant shift in our society. that we've seen in recent decades, especially in this generation, where it has become more and more acceptable to discuss things that previously were taboo and to make them known and to bring people into the details of your life, the good and the bad. And when I think about this, my mind immediately goes to topics like mental health, like sex, like a lot of details to do with our personal lives. These are no longer things to be shunned or shut away, but often at times shared in the public domain as we do on social media, as we do to create or consume authentic content. And so
对受众或那些正在倾听的人来说也是如此。我认为我们对这种坦诚程度的接受，实际上代表了我们社会中一个相当显着的转变，这是我们在近几十年来看到的，特别是在这一代人中，讨论以前被视为禁忌的事情变得越来越被接受，让它们为人所知，并让人们了解你生活中的细节，无论是好是坏。当我想到这一点时，我的脑海里立刻浮现出心理健康、性以及许多与我们个人生活有关的细节等话题。这些不再是需要回避或隐藏的事情，而是经常在公共领域中分享，就像我们在社交媒体上所做的那样，就像我们为了创作或消费真实内容所做的那样。因此，
as we as a society have become more liberal and more accepting of our capacity to be vulnerable with each other, sometimes that means oversharing. Sometimes that means kind of breaching the level of what people are comfortable with. And I think that's the main point here. Somewhere along the line, we have at times confused the idea of being honest with sharing our deepest, darkest secrets with the world. And I saw this amazing quote that I think really demonstrates the difference
随着我们作为社会变得更加宽容，更能接受彼此之间展现脆弱的能力，有时这意味着过度分享。有时这意味着有点突破了人们感到舒适的界限。我认为这才是这里的重点。在某种程度上，我们有时将诚实的想法与向世界分享我们最深、最黑暗的秘密混淆了。我看到过一句非常精彩的名言，我认为它真正展示了真实与过度sharing（过度分享），甚至在极端情况下，
between authenticity and oversharing, or even at the extreme, you know, trauma dumping. And what it said was that using vulnerability, is not the same thing as being vulnerable. We can sometimes expose personal sides of us when it's not appropriate as a resource, as a tool, as almost an emotional armor, perhaps to fast track a relationship. If you've listened to our episode on abandonment issues, you'll recognize this as a defensive mechanism where we unorganically really create closeness through excessive vulnerability,
你知道的，情绪倾倒（trauma dumping）之间的区别。它是这样说的：利用脆弱，并不等于真正做到脆弱。有时，当不合适的时候，我们也会暴露出自己私密的一面，将其作为一种资源、一种工具、几乎是一种情感盔甲，也许是为了快速推进一段关系。如果你听过我们关于遗弃问题的节目，你就会认出这是一种防御机制，我们在这种机制中，通过过度展现脆弱，不自然地创造出亲密感，
maybe too early on, perhaps because your trauma or your story still kind of owns you in a way and you don't have an appropriate outlet for feeling overwhelmed or feeling triggered by past events. So you feel the need to verbalize rather than process or in some cases, and I don't think this is that common, sometimes we overshare or we, you know, use certain stories to gain sympathy, unconsciously. A lot of these reasons, though, are not intentional. They are themselves a symptom of what we're going through or what we are finding difficult to manage. Whether that is something from your childhood or a recent fight you had with a friend or a relationship issue, when we can't find emotional closure internally and by ourselves, we look outwards, we look to
也许开始得太早，可能是因为你的创伤或你的故事在某种程度上仍然在掌控着你，而你没有适当的发泄渠道来应对被过去事件压垮或触发的感觉。所以你会觉得有必要用语言表达出来，而不是去消化它们；或者在某些情况下——我不认为这种情况很常见——有时我们会过度分享，或者我们（你知道的）利用某些故事来博取同情，而这并不是有意的。然而，许多这些原因并非出于故意。它们本身就是我们正在经历的事情，或者是我们发现难以应对的事情的症状。无论那是来自你童年的事情，还是你最近和朋友吵的一架，或者是人际关系问题，当我们无法在内心深处自己找到情感上的终结时，我们就会向外看，我们寄希望于
others to give us that closure by sharing and gaining a different perspective and looking for a certain type of either validation or feedback. I think in particular treating social media somewhat like a personal diary or approaching acquaintances as if they are your therapist, that can have serious consequences, not just for you, but also for the people that you speak to or you share with and other important people in your life. Not only can it be bad for things like personal online privacy if you're sharing every detail, but we can kind of become addicted to the validation that is provided by strangers and we're unable to regulate our own emotional reactions without their input. Also, it can put other people in a really strange position, you know, including the
其他人通过分享、获得不同的视角以及寻找某种形式的认可或反馈来给我们这种终结感。我认为，特别是像对待个人日记那样对待社交媒体，或者把熟人当作你的治疗师来看待，这可能会产生严重的后果，不仅对你个人而言，对跟你说话或分享的人以及你生活中其他重要的人也是如此。如果你分享每一个细节，这不仅对个人网络隐私等事情不利，而且我们还可能会对陌生人提供的认可产生依赖，并且在没有他们输入的情况下无法调节我们自己的情绪反应。此外，它还可能把其他人置于一个非常奇怪的境地，你知道的，包括你
people that you love. If you're bitching to some random person at a party about, your boyfriend or your girlfriend and how annoyed you are at them and dishing out all the intimate details of your relationship that might seem appropriate and fine to you you may be happy to do that but that might not sit well with that other person you're in a relationship with who would prefer to keep those things private they might feel betrayed or that they have somehow been misrepresented questioning if you know that's how you really feel about them if that's what you really think when maybe you are just oversharing is a way to vent as an emotional outlet or in a moment of anger or stress.
所爱的人。如果你在派对上向某个随意的路人抱怨你的男朋友或女朋友，抱怨你对他们有多恼火，并倒出你们关系中的所有私密细节，这在你看来可能很合适也没问题，你可能很乐意这么做，但这可能与你处于恋爱关系的另一个人不合拍，他们宁愿把这些事情保密，他们可能会觉得被背叛，或者觉得自己被某种程度地歪曲了，并质疑你是否真的是那样看待他们的，这是否真的是你内心的想法，而也许你只是把过度分享作为一种宣泄情绪的途径，或者是在愤怒或压力时刻的一种发泄。
Furthermore, I also think that this chronic oversharing can make us less approachable. It makes people around you at times feel uncomfortable. Not everyone is going to be on the same wavelength as you when it comes to honesty and vulnerability. So potentially it can lead to things like social exclusion or it can diminish the quality of your relationships. When we go as far to trauma dump as well, so this is a term referring to the tendency to unload traumatic events or experiences on others without warning or invitation, that also has more serious consequences. It can result in things like vicarious trauma,
此外，我也认为这种长期的过度分享会让我们变得更难接近。它有时会让你周围的人感到不舒服。在诚实和脆弱方面，并不是每个人都和你在同一频率上。因此，它可能会导致社交孤立等情况，或者降低你的关系质量。当我们进一步进行“情绪倾倒（trauma dumping）”时——这是一个指在没有警告或邀请的情况下，倾向于将创伤事件或经历倾倒给别人的术语——这也会产生更严重的后果。它会导致诸如替代性创伤之类的结果，
especially if the person you're talking to feels somewhat responsible for either solving your problem or feels uncertain around you as to when they will be exposed to information. that could potentially personally trigger them. I think it's important to note, as always, we like to bring nuance to these conversations. It's not black and white.
特别是如果你交谈的人觉得自己在某种程度上既有责任解决你的问题，又在你身边感到不确定，不知道什么时候会接触到可能会个人触发他们情绪的信息。我认为重要的是要指出，一如既往，我们喜欢给这些对话带来细微的差别。这不是非黑即白的。
And I do think that sharing can be incredibly healing. And this is not to say that conversations on hard things like mental health, like personal struggles, like painful experiences, are totally unacceptable
而且我确实认为分享可以带来不可思议的疗愈。这并不是说关于心理健康、个人挣扎、痛苦经历等艰难话题的对话在任何时候都完全不可接受。
at all times. In fact, I think it's the complete opposite. Honesty can be such a profound healing good thing. However, it really depends on your audience. And I guess the appropriateness of the context, not just the people you're speaking to, but also what you're going to be able to get out of the situation, right? There's some particular situations where I think we implicitly know that not only have we potentially crossed a line, but also it probably didn't really help us
恰恰相反，我认为情况完全相反。诚实可以是一件非常深刻的疗愈和美好的事情。然而，这确实取决于你的受众。我想还有语境的适当性，不仅是你正在交谈的人，还有你将从这种情况中获得什么，对吧？有一些特定情况，我认为我们含蓄地知道，我们不仅可能已经越界了，而且在当时无论出于什么原因，过度分享可能真的对我们没有太大帮助。
to overshare in that moment for whatever reason that we did. You know, sharing with someone we don't particularly know that well, especially if it is in a professional context or they're in a position of authority and that transparency has not been invited. That's a huge one. Sharing with someone who perhaps is too attached to the situation who has a vested interest. You know, I think it's a good reminder. Do not talk shit or overshare with someone's best friend that is going to get back to them or with the partner of a person you're having problems with or someone too close to the situation, some details are best kept between two individuals, but also sharing in a context whereby the kind of information you are communicating to someone
你知道，跟一个我们并不是特别了解的人分享，特别是在职业语境中，或者当他们处于权威地位而这种透明度并未被邀请时。这是一个巨大的雷区。跟一个可能对这种情况过于依恋、有既得利益的人分享。你知道，我认为这是一个很好的提醒。不要在某人的最好朋友面前说坏话或过度分享，因为那会传回他们耳中；也不要跟你有问题的那个人伴侣分享，或者跟任何离情况太近的人分享，有些细节最好保留在两个人之间；但同时，在某种语境下分享，你传达给别人的那种信息
may make them feel really uncomfortable. And if they're unable to leave, that's going to make them look at you as someone who causes them discomfort. You know, telling your co-workers that you don't really know about your childhood trauma could either bring you guys closer or it could result in a HR complaint and make people really uncomfortable. It's a bit of a risk, I guess. And we all know the feeling of looking back at a situation and realizing that we shared a bit too much, probably more than we realized we were in the moment. And we feel really embarrassed. We cringe at our past selves who, you know, potentially couldn't control the impulse or just needed to get something off their chest. So this feeling that we are talking about, it actually has a term. It is known as
可能会让他们感到非常不舒服。如果他们无法离开，那就会让他们把你视为一个带给他们不适感的人。你知道，把你的童年创伤告诉一个并不太熟的同事，可能会让你们关系更近，也可能会导致人力资源部（HR）投诉，让大家感到非常不舒服。我想这确实有点冒险。我们都知道回想某个情境时意识到自己分享得有点多的那种感觉，可能比我们在当时意识到得要多得多。然后我们会感到非常尴尬。我们会对过去的自己感到脚趾抠地，你知道的，当时可能无法控制这种冲动，或者只是需要吐露心声。所以我们正在谈论的这种感觉，它其实有一个术语。它被称为
the oversharing on vulnerability hangover. And this was coined by one of our favorite people on the podcast, Briné Brown. And what it's used to describe is that anxiety, that shame and that regret we experience after divulging something highly personal. As one New York Times article put it, as humans, we have this competing need to build social connection, but also to maintain our own private, internal lives and spaces, and also to align our behavior to what is perceived as, quote unquote, normal in broader society. So the reason we feel this vulnerability hangover is because in hindsight the next morning, we are better able to recognize that this behavior or active oversharing has kind of crossed some invisible boundary of what is and is not socially
“过度分享脆弱宿醉”（the oversharing vulnerability hangover）。这个词由我们在播客中最喜欢的人之一，布琳·布朗（Brené Brown）所创造。它被用来描述我们在泄露了高度私密的事情后所经历的那种焦虑、羞耻和后悔。正如《纽约时报》的一篇文章所说，作为人类，我们有着相互竞争的需求：既要建立社会联系，又要维护我们自己的私密内心生活和空间，还要将我们的行动与更广泛社会中被视为所谓“正常”的行为保持一致。所以我们之所以感到这种脆弱宿醉，是因为在第二天早上回顾时，我们能够更好地认识到，这种过度分享的行为或举动已经打破了某种关于社会中什么是可以接受的、什么是不可以接受的隐形界限。
acceptable. We all have this very innate sense of certain social norms that have been ingrained in us since childhood. And these norms, they are what tells us, I guess, how to act. So one of them is around understanding the line between what is public and what is private. And although that changes based on the generation we're in, we have some intuitive sense of knowing when we've crossed this, because there is certain information that we still feel an inherent drive to keep to ourselves. Crossing that line, it results in uncomfortable feelings, which is essentially our brain policing, behavior. It's our brain saying to us, that probably wasn't right. That might lead to social rejection if we keep doing that. That maybe made the other person uncomfortable. So let's fall back in
我们所有人都有这种非常天生的对某些社会规范的感知，这些规范自童年起就融入了我们的血液。正是这些规范告诉我们，我想，该如何行事。其中之一就是理解公共与私人之间的界限。尽管这会根据我们所处的时代而改变，但我们对何时跨越这条界限有一种直观的感知，因为总有一些特定的信息，我们仍然觉得有一种内在的驱动力想将其保留给自己。跨越这条界限会导致不舒服的感受，这本质上是我们的大脑在对行为进行监督。这是大脑在对我们说：那样做可能不对。如果我们继续这样做，可能会导致社会排斥。那可能让另一个人感到不舒服。所以让我们回到正轨，
line so that we don't risk social alienation. So knowing this, knowing that we have this internal almost system for preventing this behavior, why do we still do it? Why are some of us what we would term chronic oversharers, myself included at a time. So what I really want to discuss is some of the underlying psychological reasons about why we are driven or compelled to overshare, as well as some strategies to prevent yourself from feeling that intense vulnerability hangover or that shame when you've realized you've probably divulged too much personal information. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%.
这样我们就不会面临被社会疏离的风险。因此，既然知道了这一点，知道了我们拥有这样一个内部的、几乎可以防止这种行为的系统，为什么我们还要这样做呢？为什么我们中的有些人会成为所谓的“长期过度分享者”，曾经的我也是其中之一。所以我真正想讨论的是一些潜在的心理学原因，解释为什么我们会受到驱动或被迫过度分享，以及一些能够防止你在意识到自己透露了太多个人信息时，产生那种强烈的脆弱宿醉或羞耻感的策略。在短暂的休息之后，所有这些以及更多内容将为您揭晓。2%。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目“2%”中。我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，展现精神坚韧、保持健康以及培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们错了。世界上许多让我们恐慌的问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听“2%”。也就是T-W-O-Percent，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。任何男人都应该遵守两条金科玉律。规则一，永远不要招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友们》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《女朋友们》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双层贴胶带固定小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-taped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客，大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时准备在那天谈论霹雳可卡因，只是想让你们都知道我的意思。马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论的第二集了。没错。所以我开始发现其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed. That's correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台订阅《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你们最喜欢的
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite
治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的有。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们对某样东西进行追求时，
therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却仍然在继续追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在世期间做一个好人重要吗？
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同信任层面的问题。我希望你只是真正地去做一个好人。加入我和科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
那么，我们为什么要过度分享呢？为什么我们会经历那些仿佛看着自己说得太多却又无法在当时停下来的时刻？然后只能带着后悔回首过去，对自己的行为感到脚趾抠地。因此，我们接下来将重点讨论四个原因。首先，过度分享是外化我们问题或进行情绪调节的一种方式；其次，它与社交焦虑和多动症（ADHD）有关；第三，强度成瘾；最后，过度分享是为了引起注意，这不是我最喜欢的原因。
So why do we overshare? Why do we have those moments of almost watching ourselves say way too much and not being able to stop ourselves at the time? Only to look back with regret and to cringe at our behavior. So we're going to talk about four reasons in particular. Firstly, oversharing as a way to externalize our problems or for emotional regulation. Secondly, the links with social anxiety and ADHD. Thirdly, intensity addiction. And finally, oversharing is a way to get attention, which isn't one of my favorite reasons.
我认为它没有那么普遍适用，但我依然觉得它值得被承认。我们刚才已经简短地讨论了第一个原因，但有时我们会自发地透露过多信息，以此来调节当下产生的令人不适的感受。情绪调节本质上是我们改变自己对某种情绪体验的强度。这种解释、这种理论表明，过度分享本质上就是做到这一点的一种方式。这是当大脑中的声音变得太大而无法内化或压制时，在这些时刻的一种应对机制。
I don't think it's that applicable, but I still think it deserves acknowledgement. So we've spoken about that first reason rather briefly, but sometimes we can spontaneously reveal too much information as a way to regulate uncomfortable feelings that have come up in the moment. Emotional regulation is essentially the process by which we alter. the intensity of an emotional experience for ourselves. And this explanation, this theory, it suggests that oversharing is essentially a way to do that. It is a coping mechanism in these moments when the thoughts in our brain become way too loud to internalize or to suppress.
因此我们必须找到一个宣泄口，这意味着要将它们外化，用语言表达给离我们最近的人。当我们大声说出来时，我坚信问题就已经解决了一半，而且感觉没有那么强烈了。有时我认为我们觉得，A，我们要么是在削弱这种经历或故事的力量，要么是，B，通过将这种负担转移或放置在别人身上，我们在某种程度上减轻了它对我们心灵的重担。这或许可以解释为什么在向朋友好好倾诉一番之后，我们会感到神清气爽，并且在情绪上几乎感到了空虚。但在那个时刻，我们将这些信息导向了那些已经证明自己想要处于那个位置或者值得我们信任的人。
And so we have to find an outlet, which means externalizing, verbalizing to the person closest to us. When we speak something out loud, I truly believe that the problem is halved and that it feels a lot less intense. Sometimes I think we feel that like, A, we're either taking away the power of this experience or this story, or be, we're kind of lessening the burden it has on our minds by putting or placing the burden with someone else. So this may explain why we kind of feel really refreshed and almost emotionally empty after having a really good vent to a friend. But in that moment, we are directing that information to someone who has proven that they want to be in that position or that they deserve our trust.
当我们利用陌生人——一个我们不太了解的人——来进行情绪调节时，尽管这可能仍然有助于我们处理情绪，但这可能只是暂时的，并且在事后可能会让你觉得有点奇怪。我们发现自己陷入这种长期过度分享模式的第二个原因，归结于焦虑以及神经多样性。让我们先讨论焦虑。如果你是一个在紧张时会冲动说话、思绪不断跳跃、或者发现自己讲了一个又一个可能稍微有点
When we use a stranger, someone we don't know that well to emotionally regulate, although that may still help us process our emotions, it's probably going to be more short term. and it might leave you feeling a little bit strange after the fact. So the second reason we can find ourselves in this pattern of chronic oversharing comes down to anxiety and also neurodivergence as well. So let's discuss anxiety first. If you are someone who talks impulsively when you are nervous, who keeps jumping to different trains of thought or you find yourself telling story after story that may be a little bit
过于暴露的故事的人，那么社交焦虑可能就是一个解释。他们对此进行了一系列研究，在一系列研究中，研究人员发现，焦虑，特别是在社交场合中的焦虑，会导致一种被称为“自我控制耗竭”（self-control depletion）的现象，即我们变得越焦虑，我们感到的格格不入就越多，我们对冲动决策的控制力就越弱，因为我们的大脑全神贯注于试图监控我们所处的社交环境或者试图融入周围的人。一位心理学家——非常抱歉，我记不得他或她的名字了——他是这样表达的：当我们处于一个有压力或超出我们舒适区的环境时，比如对我们很多人来说是去认识新人们，
to revealing, social anxiety may be an explanation. And they did a bunch of studies on this, and in one series of studies, researchers found that anxiety, particularly in social situations, can lead to a phenomenon known as self-control depletion, whereby the more anxious we become, the more out of place we feel, the less control we have over our impulsive decisions, because all of our brain is kind of taken up with trying to monitor the social situation we're in or to try and fit in with those around us. One psychologist, and I'm really sorry, I cannot remember their name, but they put it this way. When we are in a situation that is stressful or out of our comfort zone, like meeting new people
我们会消耗大量的精神能量，试图掌控另一个人对我们的印象。我们希望他们认为我们很有趣、很酷、很招人喜欢，并且我们发现在那些时刻沉默是非常令人不适的。所以我们会想尽一切办法说点什么来化解那种尴尬感。通常最先涌上脑海的，往往是最不合时宜的话。因此，像我这样患有临床焦虑症的人——在这里我要为自己的焦虑呐喊——其实也相当敏感于拒绝和批评。所以，如果你正在和某人交谈，并且你觉得他们开始失去兴趣或者正在抽离，
for a lot of us, we use up a lot of mental energy trying to manage that other person's impression of us. we want them to think that we are interesting, that we are cool, that we are fun, and we find that silence is something that is really uncomfortable in those moments. So we kind of think of whatever we can say to manage that sense of awkwardness. And normally the thing that comes to mind is the thing that is least appropriate. So clinically anxious individuals such as myself, I'm going to shout out my anxiety here, but we're also quite you know, sensitive to rejection and sensitive to criticism. So if you're having a conversation with someone and you kind of feel like they're losing interest or they're pulling away,
你可能会试图通过抛出你生活的私密细节来重新点燃对话或重新获得他们的注意。你基本上是在说，嘿，我是值得倾听的。我有有趣的事情要告诉你，你正试图以你当时大脑能想到的唯一方式重新建立这种连接。我认为另一个真正落入社交焦虑与过度分享之间这种相互作用的重要组成部分是酒精，对吧？如果我们主要的触发因素是社交场合，特别是大型的社交场合。这些也通常是酒精出现的场合。
you might try and rekindle that conversation or regain their attention by dropping intimate details about your life. You're basically trying to say, hey, like I'm worth listening to. I have things that are interesting to tell you and you're trying to reestablish that connection in the only way that your mind is thinking of at the time. The other important component that I think really falls into this kind of interaction between social anxiety and oversharing is alcohol, right? If our main trigger is social situations, particularly big, large social situations. Those are also the times when alcohol is normally around.
我想说，这极大地促成了我生活中大多数过度分享的实例，因为我的抑制力降低了。由于我不是清醒状态，我对所处的社交环境的判断力也下降了。这导致我们说出一些平时不会说的话。这也是患有多动症（ADHD）的成年人中非常常见的现象，这并不是说这些人是故意这样做的，甚至他们也没有意识到自己做了什么。之所以会这样，是因为这种病情使得控制冲动变得更加困难。它减弱了我们在心理学上所说的执行功能技能，也就是大脑中负责说“好了，现在不是合适时机”的部分，它为你做出决定。所以当你患有多动症时，你大脑的那部分功能
And it's a massive contributor to, I would say, most instances of oversharing in my life, because my inhibitions were lowered. I have less of a good read of the social situation I'm in because I'm not sober. So it makes us say things that we otherwise wouldn't. It's also really common amongst adults with ADHD and it's not as if these individuals are doing it on purpose or they even realize what they've done. The reason why it happens is because this condition makes it harder to control our impulses. And it lessens what we call in psychology our executive function skills, the part of the brain that is going to say, all right, this is not an appropriate time. It makes the decision for you. So when you have ADHD, that part of your brain is
不如普通人那么完善，我想这么说。因此，你很难拥有那种几乎是控制安全网的东西。在网站“Understood”上有一个非常精彩的指南，该网站专门关注患有神经多样性的人群以及他们如何学习和以不同的方式看待世界。如果这个特定的情况、这个原因适用于你，绝对应该去看看。除了焦虑和神经多样性之外，我认为过度分享还与我们之前提出的观点有关，即我们渴望通过自我披露来人为地创造亲密感，从而快速推进或加深我们的亲密或社交联系。你跟你的密友会做什么？你们会分享彼此生活的
not as functional as the average individual, I would say. And so you struggle to have that kind of almost safety net of control. There's a really fascinating guide on this website called Understood, which is focusing on people with neurodivergence and how they learn and how they see the world differently. If this particular situation, this reason applies to you, definitely. Check that out. On another level away from anxiety and neurodivergence, I think oversharing also links back to that previous point we made about our desire to kind of kind of fast track or heighten our intimate or social connections by artificially really creating closeness through disclosure. What do you do with your close friends? You share personal details about
个人细节。你跟你的家人或所爱的人会做什么？你们拥有那种程度的真相和脆弱。所以这种逻辑顺理成章。这种破裂的逻辑顺理成章：如果你想让某人成为你的好朋友，就分享你的个人私密细节，这是更快达到那种关系的途径。而这有时归结为“强度成瘾”（intensity addiction）的概念。有些人喜欢他们的关系拥有这种令人难以置信的快速强度。他们想要强烈的情感、强烈的反应、高水平的脆弱、亲密和紧密。而这些人会迅速坠入爱河、迅速建立依恋，通常是通过极快地进行过度分享，渴望更快地了解彼此。
your life. What do you do with your family or with your loved ones? You have that level of truth and that level of vulnerability. So the logic kind of follows. The kind of broken logic follows. if you want someone to be your best friend, share your personal intimate details, and that is a way to get to that point with them quicker. And this kind of boils down at times to this idea of intensity addiction. There are certain people who like their relationships to have this kind of incredible fast intensity. They want big emotions, they want big reactions, high levels of vulnerability and intimacy and closeness. And these people, fall in love, become attached really fast, often by oversharing really quickly, wanting to learn
你的生活。你如何与你的家人或爱人相处？你拥有那种程度的真实和那种程度的脆弱。所以逻辑差不多就是这样。那种破绽百出的逻辑差不多就是这样：如果你想让某人成为你的最好朋友，分享你的个人私密细节，这是一种更快与他们达到那种程度的方法。这有时归结为对强度上瘾的想法。有些人喜欢他们的关系具有这种令人难以置信的快速强度。他们想要强烈的情感，他们想要强烈的反应，高水平的脆弱、亲密和紧密。这些人坠入爱河，产生依恋的速度非常快，通常是通过非常快地过度分享，想要了解
everything about someone, even the really dark things, before they realize that intensity in those moments, it may not be the same thing as actual intimacy. And I don't think it's a surprise that this is often linked to people who have a fear of abandonment or an anxious attachment style or sometimes even emotional unavailability where they're trying to self-correct and go the opposite way, but they don't really know what the balance or the middle point is. And finally, our final reason, there is this idea that oversharing is a way to gain attention or sympathy. Now, I don't think we realize this in our subconscious minds in the moment. I really don't think that most people who are chronic oversharers are going,
关于某人的一切，甚至是非常黑暗的事情，在他们意识到那些时刻的强烈程度可能与真正的亲密感不同之前。而且我认为这并不奇怪，这通常与害怕被抛弃、有焦虑型依恋风格的人，或者有时甚至是情感上不可接近的人联系在一起，他们试图进行自我修正，走向相反的方向，但他们并不真正知道平衡点或中间点在哪里。最后，我们的最后一个理由是，过度分享是一种获得关注或同情的方式。现在，我认为我们在当下的潜意识中并没有意识到这一点。我真的不认为大多数习惯性过度分享的人会这样做，
about it intentionally to get attention from other people as a manipulation tactic. Not at all. I think it's more layered than that. It's more of a learned association or a habit that has been formed or developed over time. Maybe what you found is that if you are willing to talk really intensely about your sex life or if you're willing to tell everyone very intimate details about your life, your fights, your disagreements, your past, people pay more attention to you because that is very novel. That excessive honesty is very rare. It's interesting. It's fascinating. And humans are very nosy. It's why we like tabloids. It's why we like gossip. We want to know more about the people we are interested in, but only on the surface level. So it might get someone's attention,
故意通过这种方式来吸引别人的注意，作为一种操纵策略。完全不是这样。我认为这比这更复杂。与其说这是一种操纵，不如说它是一种随着时间推移形成或发展出来的习得性联想或习惯。也许你发现的是，如果你愿意非常强烈地谈论你的性生活，或者如果你愿意告诉每个人关于你生活的非常私密的细节、你的争吵、你的分歧、你的过去，人们就会更多地注意到你，因为这非常新颖。这种过度的诚实是非常罕见的。这很有趣。这很吸引人。而且人类是非常好管闲事的。这就是为什么我们喜欢小报。这就是为什么我们喜欢八卦。我们想了解更多关于我们感兴趣的人的信息，但仅仅停留在表面水平。所以它可能会吸引某人的注意，
but it may not necessarily lead to a long-term emotional bond. I also just don't think that everything needs to be shared in order to be validated or to feel important, although it's definitely a trap that a lot of us fall into with our use of social media. It's something I've learned quite a lot recently from the person that I'm dating. You know, he is not a big social media person. And it's really fascinating to me to see the differences that we have in terms of what he thinks needs to be shared online versus what I share online. And I think sometimes I've gotten into the habit of maybe oversharing, particularly on the podcast. You know, I'm thinking specifically right now about my ex-boyfriend interview because that was
但这不一定能带来长期的情感纽带。我也只是认为，并非每件事都需要分享才能获得认可或感到重要，尽管这绝对是我们许多人在使用社交媒体时陷入的一个陷阱。这是我最近从和我约会的人那里学到很多东西的一个方面。你知道，他不是一个热衷于社交媒体的人。对我来说，看到我们在什么需要在网上分享以及我分享什么方面的差异，真的是一件非常着迷的事情。我想有时我已经养成了过度分享的习惯，特别是在播客上。你知道，我现在特别想到了我对前男友的采访，因为那
incredibly personal, but we want people's attention. We want people to think we're interesting. So we commodify very personal experiences for their benefit. And that can definitely come back to bite us as I have learned, not just in that vulnerability, hangover, but also in very tangible consequences for our relationships, for our reputation, for how people think of us. And I know that that shouldn't matter as much as it does, but I think that it really does deep down impact the way we see ourselves and how we behave. So how do we know when and with who is it appropriate to share these things with?
极其私密，但我们需要人们的关注。我们希望人们认为我们有趣。因此，我们将非常私人的经历商品化，以谋取他们的利益。正如我所了解到的那样，这绝对会反过来伤害我们，不仅是在那种脆弱感带来的宿醉中，而且对我们的关系、我们的声誉以及人们对我们的看法产生了非常切实的影响。我知道这不应该像现在这样重要，但我认为它在内心深处确实影响了我们的自我看法以及我们的行为方式。那么，我们怎么知道什么时候以及与谁分享这些事情是合适的呢？
because I'm not advocating for suppressing our feelings or hiding our experiences. I think that actually probably does more emotional damage than the occasional overshare. But like we said before, the two key factors here are context and relationship. If you find the need to externalize certain events to properly process them, that is totally okay. That is a totally fine way to emotionally regulate. but you should be doing so with someone you can trust and who you know will provide you with the response that will most benefit you. You know, don't beat yourself up for the occasional overshare or slip up.
因为我并不主张压抑我们的感受或隐藏我们的经历。我认为这实际上可能比偶尔的过度分享造成更多的情感伤害。但正如我们之前所说，这里的两个关键因素是背景和关系。如果你发现需要将某些事件外化来适当地处理它们，那是完全可以的。这是一种完全可以接受的情绪调节方式。但你应该和一个你可以信任的人这样做，并且你知道这个人会给你提供对你最有益的回应。你知道，不要为偶尔的过度分享或失言而自责。
We have all been there. I think it's part of the human experience. It's part of the learning curve. And trust me, that embarrassment will fade. But if you become a chronic oversharer and you're finding that the behavior is somewhat uncontrollable, here are some tips for regulating this habit. Firstly, when you find the need to overshare or you've found you're maybe saying things you don't want to, pause and redirect yourself, either by taking a step back from the conversation,
我们都经历过。我认为这是人类体验的一部分。这是学习曲线的一部分。相信我，那种尴尬会消退的。但如果你成了一个习惯性的过度分享者，并且你发现这种行为有点无法控制，这里有一些调节这个习惯的技巧。首先，当你发现自己需要过度分享，或者你发现自己可能在说一些你不想说的话时，请暂停并重新引导自己，可以通过从对话中退一步，
going to the bathroom or for a walk, calling a friend instead, and just turn the conversation back onto the other person by asking them a question. redirect what you're talking about. Here is a very well-known secret that I'm going to share with you today. People love talking about themselves. And giving people's space to talk about themselves will actually probably lead to greater emotional closeness than oversharing or needing to fill that silence with unnecessary details.
去洗手间或散步，转而给朋友打电话，然后通过向对方提问把对话引回另一个人身上。重新引导你正在谈论的内容。这里有一个众所周知的秘密，我今天要与大家分享。人们喜欢谈论自己。为人们提供谈论自己的空间，实际上可能比过度分享或需要用不必要的细节来填补沉默带来更大的情感亲密感。
Being an active listener as well, it also gives off so much confidence. and it makes people feel more comfortable around you. You know, watch their eyes as they talk. Be conscious not to interrupt. Ask follow-up questions. Think about things they've said that have interest you as a way to prevent yourself from being perhaps put in a place where you feel the need to share something really embarrassing.
作为一个积极的倾听者，它也能散发出极大的自信。并且它能让人们在你身边感到更舒适。你知道，在他们说话时注意他们的眼睛。注意不要打断。提出后续问题。思考他们说过的让你感兴趣的事情，以此来防止自己可能被置于一个让你觉得有必要分享一些非常尴尬的事情的境地。
Secondly, I would say figure out what triggers you to overshare. Often the reason we share details or stories about certain events is because we haven't completely integrated them. And so we still feel the need to externalize them to other people. In other instances as well, our main trigger is social anxiety or feeling really awkward or uncomfortable. So the next time you are in a situation like that where you know you have a tendency to overshare, think about other things you could say instead.
其次，我认为要找出是什么触发了你过度分享。通常我们分享关于某些事件的细节或故事的原因是因为我们还没有完全整合它们。所以我们仍然觉得有必要将它们外化给其他人。在其他情况下，我们的主要触发因素是社交焦虑或感到真的很尴尬或不舒服。因此，下次当你处于这样一种你知道自己倾向于过度分享的情况时，想想你可以改说些什么。
And think about these things in advance. lean back on your sense of self-assurance and confidence in that moment. You don't need these other people to like you if you like yourself. And I think that that feeling of oversharing and realizing what you've done is going to be a lot more uncomfortable than the short-term discomfort of a few awkward silences or thinking that maybe you made the wrong impression. Something I like to think about is that these people don't matter until they show you that they do. They are just strangers living their own lives.
并且提前考虑这些事情。在那一刻依靠你的自信和自我确信。如果你喜欢自己，你不需要这些其他人喜欢你。而且我认为那种过度分享并意识到自己做了什么的感觉，会比几秒钟尴尬沉默的短期不舒服或认为自己可能留下了错误印象的感觉要难受得多。我喜欢思考的一点是，在这些人向你证明他们重要之前，他们并不重要。他们只是过着自己生活的陌生人。
thirdly, journal instead of ranting or venting. Rechannel the urge into something that is productive. Someone said this incredible strategy to me the other day, before going into a certain situation where you might feel inclined to overshare, just spend five minutes, ten minutes before you leave, or on the train, writing down everything that might be bothering you that you don't particularly want to share with others.
第三，写日记而不是咆哮或发泄。将这种冲动重新引导到富有成效的事情上。前几天有人跟我分享了这个不可思议的策略，在进入某种你可能倾向于过度分享的特定情况之前，只需在你离开前花五分钟、十分钟，或者在火车上，写下所有可能困扰你、而你又不想与他人分享的事情。
Or call a friend and talk about those things beforehand. What that does is it gives our mind a place to actually productively deal with it rather than feeling like it's this taboo, awful thing that as soon as we have one drink we need to bring up to anyone and everyone who will listen. Fourth, in a situation where you really don't want to overshare like work functions or professional environments, avoid drinking alcohol or watch how much you're consuming. Obviously, most of us are not getting plastered at work during the day. I would hope not.
或者提前给朋友打电话谈论这些事情。这样做的好处是，它为我们的心灵提供了一个能够实际有效处理这些事情的地方，而不是觉得这是一件禁忌的、可怕的事情，以至于我们一喝一杯酒就需要向任何及所有愿意倾听的人提起。第四，在那些你真的不想过度分享的情况下，比如工作聚会或职业环境，避免饮酒或注意你的饮酒量。显然，我们大多数人在白天工作时都不会喝得酩酊大醉。我希望如此。
But after work drinks or work parties are a big source of next morning anxiety, especially after a lot of oversharing. Alcohol makes you less self-aware. It lowers your impulses. It lowers your inhibitions. And it's going to lead to some awkward stories every now and again. So I would say watch your drinks. Watch what you're consuming.
但下班后的饮酒或工作派对是第二天早晨焦虑的一大来源，特别是在大量的过度分享之后。酒精会让你失去自我意识。它会降低你的冲动。它会降低你的抑制力。并且它偶尔会引发一些尴尬的故事。所以我想说，注意你的酒量。注意你所消费的东西。
Finally, if you have found that you have overshared and you're experiencing a bit of a vulnerability hangover, a little bit of shame, I would really advise you to not grovel. Don't try and bring it up with the person. Don't excessively apologize or bring attention to it. I think we have this tendency to feel the need to do something immediately about the things that make us uncomfortable. And so you may wake up in the morning and want to message that person from the person. party and say, I'm so sorry for oversharing and, you know, I'm so sorry I'm on and on and on. I just think that brings the attention back onto the thing that you were talking about. It makes them realize that for you, it was a big deal.
最后，如果你发现自己过度分享了，并且正在经历一点脆弱感带来的宿醉和一点羞耻感，我真的建议你不要卑躬屈膝。不要试图和对方提起这件事。不要过度道歉或把注意力吸引到它上面。我认为我们有一种倾向，觉得有必要立即对那些让我们感到不舒服的事情做点什么。所以你可能会在早晨醒来时，想要给派对上的那个人发信息说，非常抱歉过度分享了，你知道，非常抱歉我喋喋不休，等等。我只是认为这会把注意力重新吸引到你刚才谈论的事情上。这让他们意识到，对你来说，这是一件大事。
And so for them, it becomes a big deal as well. You can own your behavior without needing other people to validate your experience of shame. Just try and process that on your own. or share with someone who is a close friend, realize that everything is temporary and they are less likely to remember it if you don't give them a reminder or a reason to. All right, I think that is all that I had for today.
所以对他们来说，这也变成了一件大事。你可以掌控自己的行为，而不需要别人来验证你的羞耻体验。试着自己去消化它。或者与一个密友分享，意识到一切都是暂时的，如果你不给他们提醒或理由，他们就不太可能会记住它。好了，我想这就是我今天要说的全部内容了。
I'm looking at my notes, and I think that's it. But honestly, I feel like we've covered so much. Honestly, I learned a lot. I learned so much exploring this topic that I'm definitely going to take on board in my own life. although since quitting my 9 to 5, I've definitely had fewer instances of oversharing now that I don't get drunk with my work colleagues every Friday. So I'm sending strength to all of you out there who understand that experience, who have overshared at the work party, overshared at Friday night drinks.
我正在看我的笔记，我想就是这样。但老实说，我觉得我们涵盖了太多内容。说实话，我学到了很多。在探讨这个话题的过程中，我学到了如此多的东西，我肯定会在自己的生活中践行。虽然自从辞去朝九晚五的工作以来，由于不再和同事们在每个周五喝得酩酊大醉，我过度分享的情况确实减少了。所以我向你们所有理解这种经历、在工作派对上过度分享、在周五晚上的酒局上过度分享的人发送力量。
I have done that too many times to count, but now I'm getting better at it. I'm learning more to control the impulse. I'm seeing the reason behind it and that reason being that I'm socially-enighted. And when I'm socially anxious, I just go off on a tangent and would tell you literally anything you wanted to know if it meant not having an awkward silence. So that is something I am learning, something I am realizing, and I'm trying to do better at that. So I really hope that you appreciated and enjoyed this episode. As always, if there is someone who needs to hear this, who you think might enjoy it, please feel free to send them a link and leave a five-star review
我有过太多次这样的经历，但现在我在这方面做得越来越好了。我越来越学会控制这种冲动。我看到了它背后的原因，那个原因就是我有社交焦虑。当我感到社交焦虑时，我就会扯远，字面意思上会告诉你任何你想知道的事情，只要这意味着不会出现尴尬的沉默。所以这是我正在学习的东西，是我正在意识到的事情，我正努力在这方面做得更好。所以我真的希望你欣赏并喜欢这一集。像往常一样，如果有人需要听到这个，如果你认为他们可能会喜欢，请随时给他们发送链接并留下五星好评
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. We have an Instagram if you have an episode suggestion or some thoughts, some theories, a question. At that psychology podcast, you can follow us over there, or my handle is at Gemma Speg. And as always, thank you so much for tuning in. We will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
在苹果播客、Spotify，或者你现在收听的任何地方。如果你有节目建议、一些想法、理论或问题，我们有一个Instagram。在那个心理学播客，你可以在那里关注我们，或者我的账号是Gemma Speg。像往常一样，非常感谢你的收听。我们下周将带着另一集回归。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健康和恢复力的科学。经历一些困难，你将作为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人从另一端走出。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J.
收听《2%》。即数字2%。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。《回看播客》。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个大时刻。84对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看播客》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯带来的《艰难学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy
进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这次怀孕
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
似乎是一个骗局。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次并进行了出售，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。